Mark: Can you do my intro? *laughs*
Ethan: Yeah
Ethan: HELLO everybody, my name is Mar- Uh
Ethan: I just did Wilford Warfstache. *both laugh*
*both laugh uncontrollably*
Mark: I start every video
Both: Ohhh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ethan: Alright real intro time
Mark: Real intro?
Ethan: Yup
Mark: Nah, it's good enough!
*both laughing again*
Ethan: It's fine.
Mark: Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Mario Kart with Ethan!
Ethan: Hey!
Mark: It's Ethan!
Ethan: It's me!
E: Oh do you want player one?
M: Would that matter?
E: No
*both laugh*
M: Alright, I'll take it
M: God now I gotta learn all this-
It's fucking in different places now!
M: Jesus Christ
E: The Switch controllers-
E: When you're playing with two, it's real weird
M: Yeah they got like tiny buttons at the top and then-
God now it's gonna be fucking backwards on me
E: Well do you want the normal one?
M: Naww I'll do it, I'll take the handicap it's fine
M: Uh so uh Mario Kart 8 came out for the Switch yada yada yada it's fun
I love Mario Kart  and we're gonna do Grand Bran- Grand Prix *laughs*
I wanna do 200 again *laughing*
E: *laughs really hard*
E: WHY?
M: I don't know! 'Cuz I'm a glutton for punishment? I don't even care.
E: Okay okay okay okay we'll do 200
M: Alright just for this last one. Then we'll go to 50 CC *laughing*
E: 50?! *laughing*
M: God it's gonna be a fucking nightmare. Oh man.
E: I'm gonna be Metal Mario
M: 'Cuz they recently added
200 CC very at the tail-end of the Wii U lifespan
and then all of the sudden everyone was like
"OHH IT'S SO FUCKIN' FAST"
and then they had to deal with the-
they had to deal with all the bullshit that came along with it
M: Fuckin' uh Mario Kart stats grats?
E: *chuckle*
E: I don't got the best strats-- *gagging* for Mario Kart.
M: We don't vomit on camera
M: Or do! More views!
E: More views dude
M: Go to his channel for more vomiting
*both laughing*
E: More vomiting!
E: What iz up mah *GAGGING* KREW??
M: What is up my GOOEY CREW? *laughing*
E: My Gooey Crew!
E: The thing is- is that the people watching this probably
don't know what we're talking about
M: They don't get it.
M: "OH! Mark and his goo jokes :P"
E: *laughing*
M: "He's got so many of those!"
M: Ah whatever
M: You wanna do uh... tanuki bell?
E: Yeah sure
M: Okay.... alright.
E: Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
E: *sneeze*
M: I know you probably have favorites out there but we're gonna do this one anyways
* both laughing for no reason *
M: That's pretty much all I do in my videos
E: *sneezes again* Alright.
M: So oh, last time, uh, if you go check out Ethan's channel we just played this uh we tied for second so if I don't win i'm gonna cry
E: Oh that was so nice though that we tied for second
M: It was. It kinda reminds of the videos that we do that you guys may or may not have seen
M: yet, with the making challenge as you see Markiplier making stuff.
M: It just, It's really nice when we're all like actually co-operating and not not like fighting
M: to the death over every little thing that we do
M: Oh god this fricken bike! Oh No!
E: God Dammit!
E: This is so bad!
M: I for-- I didn't realize this was a fucking bike!
*Markimoo laughs*
M: Did you know that bikes handle differently than carts?
E: No
M: They do, yeah- they don't really go faster or anything so it's like a moot point overall but they do handle
M: a *strange markimoo voice*  a little bit wonky!
E: I'm really sucking dick roight here *Both Laughing*
E: This not good.
M: Uh dude, here's the problem, you're not supposed to suck dick, you're supposed to drive the cart
E: Oh ok
*both laugh*
E: Cool cool cool, thanks (weird Ethan noises)
M: You're welcome. Feel free to goo for ya *giggles*
E: You gotta suck the goo straight from the tip.
*Both giggling*
M: You gotta get that goo out, primo source man. *laughing* Organic!
E: It's like, it's like when a snake bites you, you suck out the venom. Same with the goo dude. *Both laugh*
E: Same applies to the goo.
M: Oh jeez, I'm doing God awful right now.
E: I'm in 9'th. *Both laugh*
M: Oh,  okay, I'm not doing so bad.
E: I can't! This is so bad! And I'm not even getting good items either!
M: Well you know that's a personal problem *unintelligible goo stuff*
M: Have you done a goo check, taken it to a goo-canich?
E: GOO-canich? *Mark laughs* Uh, that's horrible.
M: It's beautiful.
E: THIS is horrible! I can't drive!
M: God, you're in 12th?
E: I'm in LAST place.
M: Thanks for making me look good though.
E: Yeah, you're welcome. I don't think we're gonna tie for second on this one.
M: Oh, you never know, man.
E: It doesn't let you fall off the map though, which is nice.
M: Yeah, that's the weird thing, it's got like guide rails on it.
M: I don't know if I'm too down with that because usually skill or whatever keep you from falling. Oh no GOO! Did you goo me?
E: That's goo from me!
M: Aw, I shoulda known that Nestor goo.
E: From my goo to you, happy holidays.
M: Ah, that's my family goo recipe.
E: Passed down from generation to generation
M: GRANDMA, PASS THE GOO! Stop hogging it!
*both dying from laughter :D*
M: Sorry.
E: *still laughing* pass the goo
*laughing*
E: This is Grandma's famous goo
*so much laugh*
M: *old woman voice* Oh, your Grandpa used to love my goo.
That's why he married me.
*both laughing*
M: I got 1st, too. I don't know how.
*such giggles*
E: I got fucking 12th. I literally got last. YOU HAVE 1ST! M: I know, yeah man.
E: Opposite end of the spectrum. M: I'm pretty good, man.
E: Pretty good goo. *Both laugh* Good goo, good goo.
M: Thanks.
M: This is just like every episode we're gonna record tonight. All about the goo.
E: All about the goo.
M: And when's it not, dude.
E: Alright, ready for the next race?
M: Yeah, yeah. Oh yeah, forgot I gotta do that.
E: Yeah, you're in charge now.
M: Fuck, we got 3 more. *giggling*
M: Can we just end there?
E: Yeah. End on a.. well, high note for you.
M: WOAH!
E: I haven't played this one!
M: I've never played this either. Woah!
M: This was on the Gameboy Advanced? Are you kidding me?
M: I always forget that people cherish the Gameboy Advance version of this one
just cos it was like ridiculously cool, but I never played it myself
so I didn't know why.
E: I never had a Gameboy Advanced.
M: You didn't?
E: Nope, I had a Gameboy Color and then a DS.
M: Oh fuck, I started off bad.
M: Yeah, I had a Gameboy Advanced and that was like my- ah AH!
E: Big monkey dragons
*Laughing*
M: That's almost correct. You're almost there, man.
E: They were turtles.
M: I don't think that's right either. I mean, I guess from a technical persective, yes...
E: Goddamn tits *giggling*
M: THOSE FUCKING TITS
E: Always *laughing* Always with the goo.
M: I hate when you're walking along and a tit drops a load a goo on you.
E: It's like, I don't want to see that out in public.
E: Do that in the privacy of your own home.
*still laughing like children*
E: I don't want to see your child trying to get that sweet goo. *has all the giggles*
M: It's corrupting our youth. *laughing* That's what it is.
M: Ah, man. If I'm going to get demonetized, I'm going to get demonetized hard.
E: Yeah... Oh, I hit bananas.
M: You hate bananas?
E: I hate them.
M: Ah, they're alright.
M: Well, actually it's hard because everything in the road is fucking yellow.
E: Mmhmm. I also hate getting coins! It's stupid and worthless.
M: No, no. You go faster if you have 10 coins.
E: *salty af* Maybe for you...
*Both laughing at Ethan's misery*
M: Sorry, I forgot.
*laughs*
E: *groaning* Noooo, Bullet Man. Get off my home.
*mumbling*
M: OH NO, you can fall off?!
M: Ah fuck.
M: Fuck, dude, I've been living my life on the edge. *laughs*
E: It was the placebo effect.
E: You just thought you couldn't fall off.
M: Well, I mean, from the last few maps it just seems
like it's just been completely holding your hand. Fuck, someone got ahead of me right at the end there.
E: I'm still..... not doing well.
M: You did so good on the last one what happened here?
E: Goddammit, I got 8th. I GOT 9TH!
E: What do you mean, I did well on the last one? I got 12th!
M: No no, like your video.
E: Oh, yeah, I don't know what happened.
M: I thought you were doing better than I was the whole time, and then you got that one 8th but
you're gonna pull it out, you're gonna pull out. *laughs* You can pull it out, man.
E: *snicker* Pull out.
M: *not helping at all* Pull out quick!
*Ethan dying*
M: The goo!
*both laugh harder*
E: Good joke that they might not get yet.
Oh, I'm gonna goo. *laughing*
E: I gotta pull out. I'm gonna goo!
*very mature adults laughing*
M: No, I think they get it. That's like music, it's a universal language.
*laughing* E: Your "Oh" face is a universal language.
E: God dammit. This is horrible.
M: Nah, man. You're doing good, man.
E: Just awful.
M: Doing goo jokes. I think that's your shining moment.
*more Ethan noise*
M: What if the video on my channel- *becomes to giggly to form words*
M: I'm sorry.
E: This is the peak of my career...
M: Oh, okay.
E: Get ready to get ghosties
*both are making random noises while concentrating*
E: This is.... bad.
M: I'm doin- I don't understand how you're doing so bad.
E: I don't either... You're in 2nd, I'm in 7th.
*oh so quietly* what is happening to me?
M: Are you drifting enough?
E: Yeah, I'm drifting around every corner. Just like Papa taught me!
M: Papa Nestor? Mark?
E: Yeah! Nobody believes me when I say that my dad's name is Mark,
or that my middle name is Mark. They're all like
"That's not true, you're just
pandering to you're audience."
*laughing*
M: Well, you do know your audience, man.
They will respond to that.
E: They will. They will.
E: No, but no one believes me for some reason.
I don't know! They're like, "There's no way that
your middle name could be Mark!" Why? Mark
is a pretty common name.
M: THERE'S ONLY ONE in the world.
E: There's only one, that's so weird.
M: *taunting* You're just copying.
*laughing*
E: You're just copying him.
M: Oh boy.
M: Is that even still a thing? I haven't seen it nearly as much as I did back in like 2013.
E: Oh, people saying that like you're copying blah blah
M: Yeah yeah, that died down which I'm very happy-
M: Oh- Oh n- I got a coin. Fuck it, I'll pay the toll blue guy.
OH!! *laughing* It didn't work..
E: Pay the toll. *both laugh* Wait, do you have to collect coins or you can't get through?
E: That would be funny. *all the giggles*
E: God dammit, I got 12th again.
M: If you slow down the video, you see like I toss the coin like, HUH. And he's just like naww.
M: *slo-mo voice* no no..
E: *in despair* I got last
M: Oh, I'm doing well though, yeah.
E: Well, that was the last race, wasn't it?
M: No, there's 3. Is there one more? Yeah there's one more
M: But I think, so long as I don't get like ass last, I
think I've got this.
E: Dude, don't worry I'll take that position. *both laugh*
E: I got you.
M: You can always count on CrankGameplays to...
E: To get last
M: ... secure ass last.
E: I like to bring up the rear. It's my style.
*Ethan huffing*
*such focus*
E: Finally, I got a good boost to start me off.
M: You are a champion dude.
E: Starting strong.
M: I think it's cuz like half of this entire episode, you've just been staring up at the ceiling laughing.
*more giggles*
E: Yeah, probably.
E: *huffing* My breathing, my breathing is all off.
M: You're never going to birth that baby now.
*laughing* E: That's been my problem the whole time.
M: You've been in labor
E: I've been in labor throughout this entire recording.
E: *groans* I just can't. I can't, I can't.
M: I mean, I'd be impressed.
M: Man, don't let anything get in the way of your videos, man.
E: Yeah. If you want to see my baby, come over to my channel.
*Mark dying*
E: What if- What if... I mean, not me cuz that's impossible.
*more laughs* E: What if someone was recording a LetsPlay and they just had a baby.
M: I mean, ya know...
E: Child labor usually isn't that short but like...
M: God, I'm waiting like it probably
already happened someone who's live
screamed a birth.
E: Probably
M: Like not even as a joke. Like that has to have happened.
E: I'd do it.
M: Ooh noo.
E: I'd live stream my own birth.
*laughing*
M: I'd go back in time, get birthed.
E: Create an Instagram account, do a sick Instagram live
stream of my birth.
M: Yeah, that sounds about right. Hey, I got 1st.
E: I didn't.
*laughing at the shame*
E: I did better though. I got 3rd. Hell yeah.
M: Yeah, not bad.
M: WAAHH-OH. I love Waluigi because normally he's moving but now he's just staying there. WAAAHH
M: Bring on the goo, c'mon please. WAAAHHH
E: Please. Goo me, goo me, goo me, goo me please.
*laughing*
E: That's the sound that he makes when goooo-
someone gives you the good goo.
M: That's Waluigi's "Oh" face. WAH
E: Wait, oh, I didn't get last! :D
M: Hey!
E: I got 11th...
M: Inkling Boy
E: Mmmm, Inkling Boy. Ink Boy. GOO BOY.
M: Ran out of goo, half way through. Alright, let's see the ceremony.
M: I hope it gives a little like, highlight of me going Coin.
E: I thought you were abut to say, "I hope it plays a small violin for you."
*Laughing*
M: That too, ya know.
E: I think it's the cart that I chose. I think it's a garbage cart.
M: The bike worked out really well for me. I was actually pretty happy about that.
M: Because the way I allocate my stats is I always emphasize acceleration versus everything.
M: Because that way, when you're bursting out of corners, it really help with the boosts
M: FUCKING RIBBON ROAD. Got robbed.
E: Got robbed on Ribbon Road cuz of the goo.
M: Alright, let's not do 200 CC ever again.
E: Nope.
M: Ahhhh- oh HUH WHAT? DUDE
*laughing*
E: Oh, I just gah- Sorry, I just gooed all over your keyboard, man.
M: AH EH! Ah, man.
*uncontrollable laughter*
E: I just love the, "HA MAN"
*record breaking amount of laughter*
M: Yeah, that's good stuff.
M: Well, thank you for having me over at your place
E: Yep *They both giggle*
E: Thanks for coming on by!
M:I think we've got to do more of this. *More giggling*
Mark: So, thank you everybody so much for watching. Check out Ethan's channel in the description below CrankGameplays.
Mark: And as always, we'll see you in the next video. Buh-bye!
Ethan: Bye!